[Music]
homie look what I become
we got the one and only Jimmy door in
the house if you don't know American
stand-up comedian big YouTuber podcast
very popular everybody's talking about
it I can't tell you how many people have
said when are we getting Jimmy on the
podcast we finally did Jimmy thank you
so much for coming out it's great to
have you on it's my pleasure thanks for
having me yes and we learned today you
like sushi you like good sushi good
sushi good sushi yeah and this one sushi
in Studio City if you say anything to
the guy he kick you out
it even says on the menu if you read the
back of the menu it says hey we don't do
uh California rolls we don't serve spicy
mayo we don't do this we don't do that
we serve fish here and you're gonna like
it and and the name of it uh it's Kazu
k-a-z-u yeah so that's the place that
Armand would talk about rafi's place he
would take me I'm like what is this just
go let them do their thing whatever they
bring just enjoy the food right what was
impressive is that you and George
Clooney dine together all the time
that's like yeah and Shatner so how did
that happen anyways so do you want me to
tell your story I'll tell that story so
my friend uh Stevo was a big
um not the Steve Stevo from Jackson you
can't just drop a Stevo right there
Korean friend of mine and he was a big
Sushi guy and I wanted to get into Sushi
I liked it and so he said the best place
is this place by his house in Studio
City and so he said he goes don't get
freaked out people just it's not going
to be a lot of people in there he said
but the people who are in there they
know and George Clooney will be there
probably I might get out of here so I go
I walk in it's Friday night at eight
o'clock I walk in and my friend is
sitting at the sushi bar he's the only
one there's no one else in there eight
o'clock on a Friday I'm like this place
can't be good so I sit down and there's
five people at a time the only other
people are five people in this table and
one of them's George Clooney that's
crazy get out of here so then uh we eat
and then so I go to the bathroom and as
I come out of the bathroom George
Clooney is like bowing to him right he's
like saying culture appropriation I've
ever seen one I do that now to him
we bow to each other when I leave we
bought each other so I and he's like
doing that and he's like saying
something to him so I like stop because
I don't want to walk in between them and
I just like I thought it'd be over real
quick but it they kept talking Anonymous
now it looks like I look like an ass
swipe I'm standing there just because
he's George Clooney was anybody else I
would just walked right through so I'm
like you cat you got to walk through now
you can't just stand there you look like
an idiot so as I start to walk through
and then I ducked my head
you know what's crazy if I can add to
that you know George Clooney tells the
exact same story I go to this place and
the only person there's this guy Jimmy
door I bow to him the whole deal here's
a crazy even crazier than that so about
a week ago maybe two I go uh my wife
saved the Boston Legal is on Hulu now
and so that's my all-time favorite show
is Boston Legal I never liked any of
those people in in acting until they
were on that show and I love them right
especially William Shatner and so I'm
sitting there again miss me and my
friend Rick over to having sushi only
people in the place in walks William
Shatner by himself sits down at the suit
so my wife had saved this this episode
and it was about how him and um that his
name is Danny Crane on the show and Alan
Shore is uh the other guy I can't think
of his real name but um they're having
they have these conversations at the end
of every episode where they smoke a
cigar and they have a scotch and they
have these heart to hearts and so they
were talking about he said you know the
one guy said my father never approved of
me and he said there's something there's
there's something there's nothing more
horrible than a father's not approving
of his son and then Denny Crane William
Shatner uh says oh my father always
approved to me right but we know as an
audience that his father disowned him
right so then he finally just snaps and
goes my father disowned me
and Alan Shore looks look at him and
says Denny I'm proud of you and he says
what are you proud of and he says I just
am I always am proud of you oh wow and
my wife saw that and she knew I would
want to see it because it really was
emotional for me and uh I couldn't it
was really a big deal for me and so then
I'm sitting there the next day William
Shatner walks in sits there and I'm just
like what the hell is crazy
and so uh so that was a big deal and we
talked and he told me he got
so he every time he would eat a piece of
fish he would look at me goes this is
amazing and I go yeah this is the best
this is the best fish so how was the
California roll though
yeah
he's proud yeah and by the way it's kind
of like and and that's our sponsor today
is the sushi spot
it can get a better sponsorship than
this FYI why did you like the clip
because you that was a cop right did you
have a good relationship with them no my
dad had two emotions angry and not angry
yet
and yeah he was what they called my dad
I come from a long line of Alcoholics my
dad wasn't a drinker he he was with uh
he's what they call a dry drunk right so
he still had all the anger and rage of
an alcoholic but we never got to enjoy
any of the fun drunk times yeah
yes so um but
um you know my dad worked two and three
jobs his whole life he put us to
Catholic school and so he he was a good
father in lots of ways you know but you
know he's just emotionally like most men
you know he wasn't available and he
wasn't really approving you know very
much I remember the first time he saw me
do stand up was in uh Las Vegas and I
was at the MGM Grand and it was a
beautiful room and I had a great show
and afterwards I go dead when they went
my parents weren't saying anything and
we're standing outside the bathroom
waiting for my little sister to get out
of the bathroom my parents weren't
saying anything and I go mom what'd you
think of the show she goes what did you
think I go I thought it went good she
goes then it went good let's eat that's
hilarious and I was like holy [__] so
then later that night later that night I
say to my dad I go Dad what did you
think of the show he goes the language
you don't even use it right and I was
just Jesus Christ I didn't know I was
just like so that was yeah so it was
crushing in a way right and then uh had
to forbid my parents from coming to my
school that's right it's the last time
you ever come yeah what was that was
that do was your comedy due to the life
that was very intense was it your way of
coping with stuff or no you were just
funny always I think it was yeah I was
the youngest I come from 12 kids right
so my
is a long story but I was the youngest
boy and then when I was in school my mom
got lonely
because all her kids are at school all
day so she went and adopted two more
kids I'm not kidding did you say 12 kids
so we had 10 kids and my mom adopted two
more what I should have yeah Baker's
Dozen family going on over there it
worked out I had one older brother I was
wow I wasn't thrilled that she adopted
someone older than me I could kick my
ass and that because I had enough of
that already right I was there you were
the youngest yeah but then I got a
little sister Rod which she adopted a
little sister so that was fun I guess I
have a little sister you had to beat her
up a little bit yeah we're gonna go Jim
and then she has triplets which are
great so anyways is
um so growing up I did talk about in my
stand-up I know my parents didn't like
because I talked about getting hit as a
kid right and they don't like that they
didn't like they didn't like hearing
that but I did we my parents uh they saw
hit us for discipline which and now as a
grown-up it's always what would I say in
my actors it's always horrible when
someone hits their kid in front of me I
never know when you're supposed to step
in you know yeah one time I was in an
airline terminal this lady's hitting her
kid he's like five years old she's
wailing on him and finally go hey why
don't you cut it out you're creeping
everybody out and she goes no you got to
hit him make some good people oh wow and
I was like wow how many punches would it
take to make you a decent
turns out 80. yeah exactly your teacher
teacher she's really nice now by the way
just just because we've been talking
about this a lot have you ever seen a
movie The Judge because the father son
you've never seen the movie The Judge
you've got to be killing me what is this
if you like that scene from the movie
you were talking about you're gonna love
the joke yeah uh Robert Robert Downey Jr
yeah
if you like like a complicated
father-son relationship this is the
ultimate Book for a movie four remember
the great Santini you ever see that yeah
no
that's the one I got to watch Talon told
you to watch that so he could cry so
that's the one I got what was that all
about that's father-son Yeah man they
play basketball again it's um it's also
yeah
it's five years before you were born
that's true I'm still turning 40.
there's some pretty heavy scenes in that
so Jacob so Jimmy is so comedy politics
okay comedy politics uh uh when I sit
there and I watch George Carlin I'm
fascinated by the guy how he would sit
there and you know take complicated and
you just poke everybody Troll make you
feel uncomfortable laugh and think all
at the same time right if you guys can
do it some don't want to touch it some
don't want to get close to it because
like look I do anything but politics I
don't want to touch it because of all
this stuff what's the risk of a comedian
talking politics well you could lose
your audience I was told not to talk
about politics right so when um after
the Iraq War
um I started to turn more political in
my comedy which year the first one or
the second one second one okay gotcha
this is 04. yes yes 89 91. so and then I
got asked to do a a show at the UCB
theater opened up and uh in Los Angeles
and they asked me if I wanted to do show
so I didn't know what to do besides
stand up right so I I was I had hurt my
back and I was watching a lot of news
and I was just like well I'll just use
video clips and talk about how crazy the
news is and how bad it is because the
news is horrible right and so that's
when I started to become more political
and everybody told my manager my
everybody the club Owners like don't
talk politics Jimmy don't talk politics
you don't want to split your audience
right well I didn't listen to him and I
just kept doing it anyway and I got an
hour special out of it and night in 2008
it was called citizen Jimmy and it was
chosen best of the Year by iTunes and
punchline magazine so I proved all those
[__] wrong good there you go
and uh and then when I then I got hired
by The Young Turks because they saw my
special and they were looking for a fill
and host and so then I I worked there
for about 10 years and that's all
politics you were with Young Turks for
10 years yeah about 10 years and what
you were there when Reuben was also
there yeah yeah that's how I met Dave
Rubin got it and yeah what did you do
with Young Turks was it with jenk and
those guys are with your own show no I
was always on the main show a lot and
except after Trump got elected they
stopped having me on and um
because uh they all became you know
Trump deranged and uh I kept telling
them you can't have four Hillary voters
on a news panel and call yourself an
alternative new show you're not
alternative to anything you're MSNBC and
so
um anyway so that I had my own show but
they put it behind a paywall and after
anyway so I left after they kept getting
Trump deranged and after the Mueller
report came out I thought everybody
would go back to normal because the
Mueller report said there's no collusion
and it was all revealed this was a big
psyop by the goddamn CIA and Democratic
party and all blah blah blah and uh they
didn't they didn't stop and they just
jumped on another horse and kept going
and I was just like I gotta get out of
here so I left and then uh it all went
to [__] because their executive producer
when I did Force the vote I don't know
if you guys ever heard about that so
when the uh the squad got elected AOC
and those people they all got elected
and we're going to oppose the
establishment of the democratic party
we're going to oppose Nancy Pelosi we're
going to pull we're going to be the
progressives you know and and so I was
like okay so they won and then it was
such a small margin that the Democrats
held just like now with the Republicans
and so to vote for the speaker just like
they just did this time for McCarthy I
we wanted them to withhold their vote to
extract something and what we wanted in
the middle of a deadly pandemic as they
said uh well we want to vote on Medicare
for all because everybody on the
quote-unquote left had agreed for over a
generation that getting a vote on
Medicare for all and the house floor was
a big deal and we should achieve it even
in the DSA the Democratic sources of
America in their handbook in 2019 it
said the biggest thing we could do is
get a vote on Medicare for all and so I
came up with the idea hey it's like
eight votes or something it was very low
and I said so if you withhold your vote
for for Nancy Pelosi's speaker she can't
become speaker and what she should
demand is a vote for Medicare for all
because AOC had said that as she was
campaigning she said we can't even get a
vote for Medicare for all on the house
floor we can't figure a vote that's
horrible and then she said the
Democratic party is a conservative party
it's a center-right party those are
words that's verbatim from AOC so we're
like okay so now we're going to oppose
we're going to bring the Democratic
party back to the left we have leverage
just like the Republicans just had with
McCartney Matt Gates and those guys they
had leverage they got a lot of stuff
they did good and they yeah I mean they
brought McCarthy to his knees he's 15
50. yeah that's insane right yeah and so
then and so what we wanted them to do
that they wouldn't do it and they kept
making up all these excuses why they
wouldn't do it now's not the time this
and then they got a lot of people in the
media like The Young Turks to [__]
for them and uh guys like Ryan Grimm at
the intercept and they would they would
rant interference and tried to muddy the
waters it's a very simple morality play
and they try to make it complicated like
it was hard to do and and so uh we were
Vindicated because Matt Getz and the
right wing just did the exact same thing
to McCarthy and people were lying by the
way so when I said they should do they
would go no if we do that Kevin McCarthy
will come become speaker which is a lie
they can't happen and we should Kevin
McCarthy couldn't become speaker when
the Republicans have the goddamn house
so that was a big deal that was forced
to vote and um I've been Vindicated I
mean the people who have supported it
lots of people supported it it wasn't
just me it was guys like Cornell West
guys like Chris Hedges Bernie Sanders
former press secretary Brianna Joy gray
Medea Benjamin there's a murian
Williamson there's a lot of people that
were on board for this and I would say
about half the people who were Bernie
Sanders supporters maybe all of them uh
they didn't do it they got exposed and
now uh they're just go along play alongs
and there's no reason to vote for
Democrats at all today today you believe
that yes I tell people that if you have
any morality you will not vote for one
of these two pro-war anti-worker parties
you will vote for a third party and
people say well Jimmy if you do you know
third parties are not viable at so what
they're really saying is you can't vote
for a third party until a lot of people
are already voting for third party well
how do you get started you have to start
voting for a third party and that's my
and so we got to stop donating to them
we have to take you know there's only
one party in America with very very
little differences you know that right
your point is what with the people who
are behind it with the money that
they're giving so they have to kind of
please the same people and how well
years ago you know Obama and Clinton's
you know were bought by Wall Street and
then on the right is that yes okay yeah
you got it
yeah uh in 2020 let's do this so I want
to go into these topics I want to talk
to you about the Trump the comments you
met if the Trump uh uh you know uh the
the folks who had a hard time dealing
with Trump are they over it are people
ready for him to come back is it
DeSantis is it a Tulsa gabbard I know
you're a big Tulsi fan and then I want
to also talk about some other issues
that's going on with Bernie Bernie
commented something on teachers minimum
wage going to sixty thousand dollars for
teachers I have some thoughts on that I
want to react to a video I saw about
John Kirby being pushed on questions I
don't know if you saw this or not I
think you'll appreciate this he's being
he's being challenged pretty hardcore on
NATO and what NATO is doing and the
responsible before we do that I want to
go to our Sushi sponsor today actually
our sponsor today's goldco okay so shout
out to Gold Coast you guys know I've
been talking about finances and money
and Investments for many years and I've
been talking about gold for I don't know
six seven eight years and I've been
buying gold for many years and not
because it's 10 portfolio five percent
portfolio it's one or two percent
portfolio where I recommend people
hedging against what could potentially
happen specifically now you saw what
happened with inflation the numbers came
up uh what two days ago 6.4 percent it's
up a half a percent that we're not
expecting this to be the case this means
Powell still has to keep increasing
interest rates whether it's going to be
a quarter of a basis point or a half or
maybe even a three-quarter basis point
the next chance he gets last year they
raised the rates seven times we've
already raised it once this year so if
you are somebody who is looking at
investing to Gold I highly recommend you
look into goldco uh We've called around
we did our own research before we
decided who to go with guys who used to
work with this company are very good
friends of mine who haven't been with
them but they speak very highly about
the Integrity of the company goldco so
if you do want to take advantage of a
value 10 years could get up to ten
thousand dollars in free silver and a
free one ounce silver Ronald Reagan coin
with a qualified order column today
eight five five five nine four two seven
five eight once again eight five five
five nine four two seven five eight or
go to goldco.com forward slash pbd okay
so let's get right into it Trump you
talk about Trump earlier and how you
were working at Young Turks and how the
fact that they had four people who were
pro-hillary similar to what MSNBC was
there's nothing different about you and
what their slogan was that's not where
you are alternative you know media right
and their challenge was 26 and they
won't bring you a lot because of trump
do you think America is still dealing
with that or do you think Trump has an
opening to make a comeback or is
everybody kind of saying if anybody from
the opposite side does become a
president it's got to be anyone but
Trump which means the sentences who
we're okay with
yeah I mean I'm not good at predicting
stuff like that but I do I do feel like
that a lot of the Republicans that did
support Trump are kind of ready to move
on that's my sense I could be wrong who
knows when maybe he goes out and gives a
couple of speeches and people get riled
up again and they and it all happens
again
um but people saw him as a as
anti-establishment and he's a
billionaire which is kind of wild and
but you know people the reason why I try
to tell people why do you why do you
think the establishment hated Trump so
much it's because they do they couldn't
control him as much as they could
control other people and he was uh
compared to Joe Biden and Barack Obama
he was an anti-interventionist compared
to those guys right and um he he did
campaign on uh ending the wars and stuff
like that and he he wasn't uh as bad as
what's going on right now what's going
on right now is what we were told Trump
was going to do saber rattle with
nuclear powers and he's a madman and he
can't have his finger well that's what
they're doing right now right and so in
2016 when they cheated Bernie Sanders is
when I I stopped being a Democrat and
then Bernie Sanders didn't make them pay
a price for it they didn't make them
reform he didn't make them stop cheating
progressives he didn't make him stop
taking corporate money he didn't use his
leverage one bit he didn't ask his
followers to get in the streets and to
protest or do anything and he never will
because Bernie Sanders uh although he
espouses all the right things uh doesn't
have a backbone or a spine and he's
there it's kind of obvious now if you if
you're not look he's there to make sure
all the Revolutionary energy and the
progressive energy that is on the left
gets funneled back into a pro-war
anti-worker pro Wall Street party and
that's all he's doing is there's a
politician who I'm fond of shama sawant
in Seattle and she says that the road
for progressives inside the Democratic
party leads to a graveyard and it's
exactly right I mean Joe Biden
campaigned on 15 minimum wage he didn't
he's not doing it he campaigned on
giving people Health Care through the
public option they're not they don't
even bring up Health Care they don't do
anything in the middle in the middle of
pandemic this country is so corrupted
they won't give people Health Care in
the middle of a pandemic but they will
sell to send 100 billion dollars to the
most corrupt country in Europe Ukraine
and without any oversight to how that
money is being spent there were those
weapons I would I say when I go on stage
in Los Angeles I go I don't care if they
send 100 billion dollars to Ukraine I
just wish they'd set 100 billion dollars
to the United States how about we send a
couple billion dollars to La Miami New
York Philadelphia Minnesota and then we
can maybe fix homelessness because it
because a hundred billion dollars could
end homelessness about five it's
unbelievable people have no idea how
much 100 billion dollars is or the fact
that you know they said Trump was a
madman and they increased his military
budget 132 billion dollars while he was
President well if he's a Madman why are
you giving him more money to go do
warrants though because it's not about
him being a Madman it's about the
military-industrial complex as a
Stranglehold on our government and
that's exactly what's happening I want
you to watch this I mean everybody in
the Progressive every one of the squad
they've voted for that
and the only people standing up against
it other people on the right so things
are flipped now so very weird very weird
and by the way if there's one thing
that's been constant about Trump
he's been anti-war for a long time
didn't he buy like a two-page center you
know ad on USA Today or New York Times
it was to talk about Bush's war and how
you know you know how they were so upset
how could you do it you're a republican
no he's a Democrat no he said this is
what's happening today which is kind of
weird is the following I want to get
your thoughts on this and I want you to
watch us what John Kirby just went
through is
I wonder if Democrats are kind of
sitting there saying dude I don't I
don't know if I'm a Democrat like I
don't like I am a Democrat I'm a
registered Democrat I've always voted
Democrat but dude I'm not for that and
I'm not for this and I'm not for that
where you know the Republican party for
a lot of people's like I will never be a
republican are you kidding me to
associate with these war mongerologies
and here like so who do I vote for today
so you're talking independent
libertarian then the conversation comes
about who can actually win today who can
get the job done today who do I trust
today the more and more you're listening
to different people's views I wonder if
the voter is kind of confused saying
dude I don't know what to do what do I
do next the only difference between a
Democrat and a republican as Ralph Nader
said is the speed at which their knee
hits the floor when a donor walks in the
room and so it doesn't matter who's
President Barack Obama was not a
departure from George Bush he was a
continuation of George Bush he took us
from two Wars to seven wars he kicked
5.1 million families out of their homes
while he made sure the bankers didn't
miss their bonuses he deported twice as
many Hispanics as Donald Trump he he
built those cages that put those people
and he dropped 26 000 bombs in fact the
Air Force ran out of bombs that's a fact
they ran out of bombs he dropped so many
bombs he did a drone War a drone program
that killed 90 innocent people you know
if somebody walks into a mall and shoots
15 people down with this gun that's the
biggest thing oh my God Barack Obama was
doing it on a daily basis killing women
and children with his drone war and and
he got a Nobel Peace Prize he got a
Nobel Peace Prize he didn't even do
anything that's him and so it's a it's a
uni party it's the and so when Trump got
in office and he mentioned that there's
a deep state they're like you can't say
that what are you doing and when he said
hey when they asked him why are you
leaving your troops in Syria and he said
for the oil
yeah because no it's for the old no it's
for Liberty it's for helping the people
no it's for the oil it's our oil and so
he let the cat out of the bag and they
can't have that that's what he blew the
whistle on what's actually going on our
Wars are for oil our Wars are economical
Wars just like what's happening in
Ukraine this is an economic War we're
trying to put a hurt and isolate Russia
we're afraid of Russia and their natural
resources and their Manpower coming
together with Germany with their
technology and their capital and we've
been saying that for decades and so
that's why we blew up the Nordstrom
Pipeline and that's why this Ukraine war
is happening uh and people have no idea
what's happening and what's worse is
they have no idea that they have no idea
what's happening that's the crazy part
can you play this clip it's so
interesting when you watch this the guy
that's asking a questions is so common
poised and he gets rattled watch this
to look at this and say the reason that
the Russian army is on NATO the Russian
army is at NATO's doorstep is because
NATO has expanded
rather than the Russians expanding that
in other words NATO has moved closer to
Russia rather than Russia moving closer
to Nato is that not an accurate way to
look at this I think that's the way
President Putin probably looks at it
it's certainly not the way that we look
at it you don't you don't think that
NATO has expanded Eastward toward Russia
NATO has expanded and the expansion is a
good thing for the reason that the
Russian army is that NATO's doorstep is
not the fault of the Russian R not the
it's not the Russian army that's done it
it's NATO has moved closer to movies
sure it wasn't NATO who was ordering you
know upwards of 15 Battalion tactical
groups to within 10 kilometers of the
border with Ukraine and I'm pretty sure
it wasn't NATO who put Little Green Men
inside Ukraine to destabilize eastern
city sure that Ukraine is not a member
of NATO so unless that's
cheaper the movement by Russia
if NATO has moved East the reason that
the Russian army is closer or on NATO's
doorstep is because NATO NATO is not a
anti-russia Alliance NATO is a security
system
for 50 years it was an anti-soviet
alliance so would you not understand it
do not understand how can you not even
see other Russians and perceive it as a
as a threat and the fact that it keeps
getting closer to their border while
their troops I mean the the places where
their troops are you say their troops
are and may have been in Ukraine and
Georgia are not NATO numbers I don't
have I'm not going to pretend to know
what goes in President Putin's mind or
Russian military commanders I mean I
barely got a history degree at the
University of South Florida well I can
tell you what I can tell you Israel is
that NATO is a defensive Alliance it
remains a defensive Alliance fair enough
but it has moved East correct I mean
that's just the thing that's expanded
absolutely exactly there's no reason for
anybody to think the expansion is a
hostile
and we've been saying that throughout
the last 15 years
you're moving closer to Russia you're
blaming the Russians for being close to
Nato that's exactly what we're blaming
the Russians for violating the
territorial Integrity of Ukraine and
destabilizing the security which is not
a NATO member which is not a NATO
I see other countries feel threatened
nothing makes me happier than when you
actually see a really good reporter that
has the balls to do stuff like that and
is in silence because they're scared
about losing their job that's some I
love things like that but that's a guy
named Matt Lee that journalist good guy
named matley what are your thoughts when
you see that well it's obvious that they
don't want you to know the real history
they don't want you to know that when
Germany was allowed to reunify the
promise from NATO to Russia was that we
won't expand NATO and then of course it
did I think there's 13 13 or something
more countries that they put into NATO
and now they wanted to put Ukraine into
NATO or threaten to do that that would
be like if Russia got into a military
alliance with Mexico and they wanted to
start putting military bases in Mexico
we wouldn't allow that we wouldn't allow
it and just like what happened with Cuba
with the missile crisis in the 60s we
wouldn't allow stuff like that but we're
doing that and people don't they don't
want you to know that this NATO is not a
defensive it is offensive this is a this
is a war that was started and provoked
by NATO and the West zielinski ran on
peace he brought on bringing the country
back together right the Russian speakers
in the East the Don bass but he didn't
do it so why because he got threatened
by NATO and the ultra right the Nazis in
uh Ukraine and so they'll they
threatened to kill he knows he's a dead
man if he does a peace deal with uh
Russia so that's why he won't and when
they had a peace deal in March and
that's when Boris Johnson from the UK
flew there and said hey you better you
don't do this and he he killed the peace
deal so Russia is the one that wants
peace in this deal and Ukraine and NATO
do not they want to bleed Russia
economically and that's why they blew up
the Nordstrom 2 Pipeline and they
allegedly yeah they've always said they
were going to do it and they did it uh
and I don't what for the life of me I
can't get why the European nations are
going along with this uh they've said
stuff like uh there was the foreign
minister of Germany said I don't care
about my people if they don't want this
I care about the people of Ukraine What
leader of a country says they don't care
about their own people but they care
more about somebody else's country it's
crazy what's going on so people don't
realize that NATO has provoked this in
fact there was a peace agreement in 2014
the CIA helped overthrow the Ukraine
government and and then uh the people in
the Don best didn't want to go along
with this cude government right because
the leader of Ukraine wanted to be
friendlier economically with Russia
instead of joined like the European
Union and that they couldn't have that
right so that's why they did a coup and
the people the Russian speakers and the
donbaths didn't want to go along with
that coup and so they kind of wanted to
break away Ukraine government started
shelling the Don bass and so they had a
peace agreement called the mints
agreements and that was supposed to give
them Independence they were supposed to
have their own elections and they were
going to stop shelling them they never
did they ended up killing like 14 or 15
000 people in the Don bass over the last
eight years and now it's been revealed
that that peace agreement was never real
the uh a Merkel the former prime
minister of Germany just admitted that
the only reason they did that peace
agreement was to give Ukraine enough
time to build up its military so when
they finally did provoke an invasion
which is what they did that they would
have a military ready to fight uh Russia
and so people don't know this is what
happened and so they just think that one
day Putin woke up and said I want to go
invade Ukraine because I'm a maniac and
they think that he's the bad guy they
think that he's he's acting rationally
he's acting we always knew he would do
this in fact we were counting on him
doing this that's why we did what we did
and they don't know that Ukraine ramped
up their bombing right before the war
started last year they doubled their
bombing they were really trying to
provoke it and they did and they got
they provoked it and the Russian would
rather have a peace agreement uh at the
rest of the world would rather have a
great peace agreement not NATO not Joe
Biden not the military-industrial
complex and so that's where we are uh
and people don't know that and that's
what that is that guy's saying hey
NATO's the ones expanding the reason why
uh he just he said it the reason why
that NATO's Army is on the doorstep of
Russia is because we moved not Russia
and it's just obvious that we're the Bad
Guys the United States is the world's
terrorists we have a thousand military
but you know we have 400 military bases
surrounding China since the Korean War
we just added three new military bases
in the Philippines they just announced
two weeks ago this is how all Empires
end we're ending we're overextending
militarily while we have people living
under every bridge people don't have
health care a living wage half the
country can't afford a 500 emergency 80
percent of workers live paycheck to
paycheck 50 of wage earners earn thirty
thousand dollars or less people go
bankrupt when they get sick in this
country we have homeless people
everywhere and that's because our
government is a hundred percent
corrupted it's the people think that's
corrupted like oh Joe Biden gave his kid
a no-show job in a Ukraine energy border
Donald Trump gave his kid a deal with
the South no no no that's regular
corruption I'm talking about 100 percent
everything the government does it only
does it because of corruption and that's
the only way the wheels get greased is
through corruption that's why we can
send a hundred billion dollars to
Ukraine without any oversight and we
still won't send it to our own cities to
fix our homelessness or our bridges that
those homeless people are living under
we won't even fix our own goddamn
country so people don't realize that
this is pretty much a Banana Republic
we're we're at the end this is the end
of this Empire uh we're basically Brazil
with a couple of big cities that are
keeping it afloat uh you think so yeah
you believe that yes yeah well when when
half the country can't afford a 500 more
this is what I like to say what do you
call a system that takes the richest
country the face of the Earth has ever
seen and renders half of its population
poor low income you call that a failed
system and that's where we're living in
and people think we're going to be able
to vote our way out of this what we have
to do is get people in the streets so
when someone like AOC has 13 million
Twitter followers and Bernie Sanders
says they're supposed to tell people to
get in the streets shut stuff down
protest and take our government back but
they won't because they're part of the
system and that's what I'm trying to
wake people up and it's worse off having
people like Bernie Sanders and AOC in
the Democratic party in government even
though Bernie claims is an independent
he's a Democrat and be why is it worse
because it gives people the false
impression that there's somebody
actually fighting for you in government
so there isn't so so okay the only way
you can have change you get people into
the streets is when they lose faith in
the system and we have to get them we
have to disabuse them of the idea that
there is somebody fighting for them in
this system and there isn't so so you so
I was going to ask you what's the
solution you you just said the solution
is to get people to lose faith in the
system a part of it and get Industries
to lose faith in the system okay so
let's just say let's let's play that
let's let's say that happens okay let's
say somehow somewhere AOC and Bernie
Sanders listen to this and they have a
change of heart and they said Jimmy
you're right and they tweet out on
Twitter today and they say Jimmy's right
okay let's take it on the streets and
let's go everywhere and let's protest
against this fantastic then what
uh that's when we that's how things
change that's how we got civil rights
what should change that's how women got
their own what should change what so
when we get money out of politics is the
first thing we got to get money out of
politics and so it's the honey we I I
would recommend uh public financing of
our elections and we shorten our
election season all there's a million
things you could do that way but
definitely get money out of politics you
want to have election uh campaign
Finance reform right that's number one
on your list that'll never change that
would be so that's what I mean until we
shut stuff down I mean the truckers
showed that you could bring them to your
need their needs and in Canada yeah yeah
and so and you know of course people in
the United States they listen to the
corporate media they call those people
Nazis when they're actually Freedom
Fighters and they were right they
weren't fighting against medicine the
truckers were vaccinated at a higher
rate than the general population in
Canada they were fighting against
authoritarianism and they were right and
America look at those truckers and they
call them Nazis and they look at Nazis
in Ukraine and they call them Freedom
Fighters that's how messed up our
corporate media is Jimmy so let's but
let's go with that I'll tell you one
more thing I want you to keep going
though so give me more that was very
good point but keep going so what
happened in Staten Island at the Amazon
warehouse Christian Smalls is a black
guy who got fired and then he decided to
uh organize a union and he organized
along class lines so a lot of people on
the left in the Democratic party said we
have to organize along class lines they
don't mean it because what organizing
along class lines means is you're going
to organize with trumpers you're going
to organize with because you're in the
same class and that's exactly what
Christian Smalls did on Staten Island
you know you know Staten Island is a
bunch of trump voters and so he went and
organized those people because they have
a common interest and they had they have
a they have a a common enemy and that is
the establishment and the oligarchy and
you put down your your differences
politically and you join together on a
class basis and you uh that's how you
make change and so we need more of that
we need more people coming together
unless the left and the right realize
that we do have common interests which
we do we want to we all want to stop the
war machine we all want to stop this
authoritarianism around kovid we all
want to stop a lot of things right so if
we could come together and realize we're
being screwed because our government is
a hundred percent corrupt then maybe we
could get something done you know
um I had a Boogaloo boy on my show now a
lot of people conflate Boogaloo boys
with proud boys but they're not Boogaloo
boys are a response to the proud boys
Boogaloo boys we're a pro lgbtq they
were pro-black lives matter their
anti-war they were anti-trump and they
were anti uh cop
so I'm like oh my God that's we agree on
a lot of things I didn't know that well
they can't so the establishment the
Democratic party they did a smear
campaign against me they still do it to
this day just because I interviewed a
Boogaloo boy on my show I didn't I
didn't hire him I didn't go we just had
an interview just like you're
interviewing me that doesn't mean you're
you know you're validating what I'm
saying you're just interviewing me same
thing so that's house and that is the
thing that scares them if the left and
the right organize on class lines that
is the thing that would really stand
we're doing an anti-war rally on the
19th this Sunday at the Lincoln Memorial
in in Washington DC and we got people
from the left we got people from the
right we got people from the center we
got all kinds of people to oppose War
that's what gives it its power if it was
just a bunch of progressive lefties it
wouldn't have any power but the fact
that there's Ron Paul's going to be
there he's going to be speaking so
that's a big deal and Tulsi gabbard's
going to be there and uh you're getting
Ron Paul out of Houston yeah he never he
never leaves Texas this is a big deal
that he's going to be here so anyway
that's we have to do more things like
that that's the only way to take back
our government is to get in the streets
shut stuff down and you know in France
uh they have eight they have their
they're going to try to raise their
retirement age from 61 to 63. you know
they're raising in the United States is
67. they they already have Medicare for
all they already have dental they have
retirement social security and they
still get in the streets and shut [__]
down all the time and I don't know if
you've ever been uh we were in Italy it
was like oh the trains aren't going to
be running today there's going to be a
strike they do it all the time wearing
back Mussolini in the rest of the world
the left is connected to the working
class except in the United States the
Democratic party is a bunch of their
their core constituency are Suburban
white people that they they admitted it
Chuck Schumer said they go hey when
Hillary was running against Donald Trump
they're saying hey Donald Trump's
picking up blue collar voters and he
said doesn't matter for every
blue-collar voter we lose we're going to
pick up two or three white collar
Suburban voters and you can repeat that
in Ohio and Wisconsin he said that I
haven't I played on my show all the time
of course he was wrong they lost the and
so they don't care about the blue collar
voters they don't care about the workers
that's not their constituency it used to
be their remote that's why there's
nobody representing them anymore that's
right that's what gave Donald Trump his
power because he spoke to those people
Jimmy who's anti-establishment today on
the left or the right who's
anti-establishment today left right
middle libertarian who are some of the
names Ron Paul being one of them who
else would you see I I'm you know I
don't have any faith in any of the
politicians right now there's a woman in
Seattle shama Sawan uh she had to fight
the Democratic mayor in the Democratic
City councils to get a 15 minimum wage
she has to fight the Democrats to get
stuff the Democrats and the Republicans
serve the same people they have the same
neoliberal corporate interests and so I
don't I don't I don't know anybody in
politics that I would really uh go away
I used to like rocon I used to like AOC
I used to like all those Bernie Sanders
but none of them will stand up for what
they claim to stand for and they all
roll over for the establishment they all
voted for war
but Jimmy okay so let's say not politics
who outside of politics because you need
some of the guys that are from the
outside to get in the inside people like
Chris Hedges I like Paul Dennis kucinich
is out of politics right they they so he
was they gerrymandered him out right the
Democrats are like f you you're you're
too much of a progressive and they get
rid of them and he's done so um I I
don't I like people like Chris Hedges I
like people like Dennis kucinich I loved
the way Tulsi stood up against the war
machine in Syria uh unfortunately she's
still for the Drone program but so what
she's better than everybody else and
when it comes to Syria and that's why
they people don't realize why they hated
uh uh Tulsi so much is because she
stepped down from the being the vice
chair of the Democratic National
Committee to endorse Bernie Sanders can
I ask some names and here's what I want
you to do okay from zero to 100 give a
score okay give a score of where they're
at 100 being full-blown establishments
zero being anti-establishment okay fair
Ron Paul
you know I don't know all I know is how
much I love the way he talks about I do
too just give a number what do you think
nobody's gonna fact check you that's
your opinion I would say I don't know 67
okay it's all together maybe 50 I don't
know Tulsa yeah
uh I can't this I I don't really like
this uh I tell you why I'm asking this
question I'm really I'm really curious
because if you if you don't mind so what
do you think Tulsi is zero to a hundred
uh you know she's showing I would say
50. okay what would you say Newsome is
uh hundred McConnell 100 McCarthy 100.
McCarthy's son Matt Gates
uh I don't know 70. okay interesting
that's why I'm asking a question AOC
wait when Matt gate stood up against
work I agree with you he's putting in an
anti-legislation to stop the funding of
the Ukraine and by the way the case
against them was dropped yesterday I
don't know if you saw that or not okay
how about uh how about AOC
I I 100 okay Bernie well Bernie's
actions are a hundred okay uh Trump
uh
well he went you know he's like I said
he he wasn't an imperialist as much as
other people were he was but he wasn't
as much
um
he did talk about the Deep state but he
didn't do anything he said he was going
to do he said he was going to bring
everybody jobs he was going to give
everybody health care and he didn't do
any of those things but he did give
people he did give millionaires him a
trillion dollar tax cut just like
everybody and so why do they hate him
they hate him because he once in a while
would tell the truth that you're not
allowed to tell like there's a deep
stage a permanent state that actually
runs things there's uh and Chuck Schumer
also also said that about Donald Trump
when he when Donald Trump was telling
people that the CIA and the FBI there
was a deep State and they're the ones
pulling the strings out this stuff Chuck
Schumer said it's really foolish of him
to do that because uh if you go against
the CIA they got six ways this Sunday to
get back again now that's the leader of
the democratic party in the Senate
saying that this President of the United
States should be afraid of the CIA he
said it on [__] camera and nobody and
everybody was like Trump's crazy what no
Chuck Schumer just told you who runs
this goddamn country and the president
better watch his ass he better not cross
the CIA that's what the leader of the
Democratic Party said who by the way
he's not a leader he's a puppet of Wall
Street how does a guy like Chuck Schumer
who I know you wouldn't even ask
directions to the [__] freeway from I
wouldn't either these guys how does he
get to be a leader because he's the
biggest him and Mitch McConnell right
they get they get uh they're the biggest
marks Wall Street military industrial
complex health insurance big Pharma they
give them all the money because they're
the most corrupted and then they take
that money and they give it to their
colleagues so they can go get reelected
and then they have to vote for them as
leader not because they're leaders but
because of the most corrupted pieces of
[__] in Congress and that's why the
countries like the way it is right now
because we're run a hundred percent by
corruption okay so Trump's wrote a
hundred
like I said I would
85 okay so go to Nikki Haley I don't
know Nikki Haley okay let's just keep
going but I didn't see Don Lemon yeah
that was not good how about the
scientists the Santas
uh I I don't I I DeSantis was was better
on covid than other people
so I would say 95. okay uh so you give
Trump Lord in the sentence interesting
so how about Michelle Obama 100 Hillary
Clinton 100 okay fine so now let's let's
do something let's I'm gonna I'm gonna
ask you a question let's stay on this
topic here so if if out of everybody you
said it's interesting you identify
yourself as a you would would you say
you're a progressive uh uh again I don't
want to put words in your mouth what
would you say you are yourself
politically
I would say I'm politically homeless uh
I but I I call him I used to call myself
a progressive I don't do that anymore
because Hillary Clinton started calling
herself a progressive so I can't be that
so I just called myself a lefty or an
old style Lefty old style Lefty yeah
you're not John F Kennedy Lefty right
wow well I mean he see I killed him
right I mean I don't know what that mean
I mean I'm an RFK Lefty I know that okay
um so yeah I mean I'm anti-imperialism
I'm anti-war machine I'm pro-worker I'm
pro-medicare for all I'm free speech ABS
I'm you know people say oh is it is an
absolutist yeah yeah that's why we have
a First Amendment and the answer to bad
speech is more speech not censorship as
we're learning through the Twitter files
yeah so so for me you know you know what
I think about I think you know people
are gonna clip this and say look Jimmy
Dore says DeSantis of course Jimmy Dore
says Trump is anti-establishment I'm not
saying that I'm saying they are the
establishment they're still going to do
it by the way just so you know there's
no going to clip this I know so you know
that but but here's a here's the
question for you so
you think the right person for the job
is ever somebody you fully like
uh no okay so you think the right person
for the job you have to like a hundred
percent of everything they do and you
have to agree a hundred percent with
what they agree with no okay so could
the person that's the right person what
are the qualities of the right person
for this job so purely not policies but
qualities what are the right qualities
of somebody that would be the right
person for this job to go against the
establishment qualities we need someone
I was uh we need someone who's actually
going to stand up
for what they believe in shama sawant
she's the real deal qualities give me
qualities
her quality is honesty integrity
uh and I don't know what the word would
be but um like her salary she will only
take as much money as the average salary
in her district and she gives the rest
away
that's a real deal I don't know what you
call that but she's real and she put
she's she's where the rubber meets the
road and that's the kind of politician I
look for people who care they they know
what it's like to struggle can she be
bought I don't think she can be okay so
so let's let's put that down I think I
think we're getting something so you
said honest Integrity which by the way
it's very hard for us to really measure
that those qualities you know that that
takes five ten years until we really
know if a person is honest and has
Integrity but you said is not for sale
okay let's put that right what else
let's let's let's figure out some of
these qualities here is it fair to say
that the person uh uh cannot be afraid
of being trash destroyed labeled [__]
talked about you know backstabbed you
cannot figure what do you call that do
we want to put thick skin yeah is that
fair okay I would say what else would
you say for the quality of this person
uh uh courage courage what else I agree
did they have their own money do they
have to be does it help if they have
their own money you know that that's I
mean shamason certainly doesn't so I
know I think Integrity no I mean are you
sure like it like for like
it's like if someone like you ran right
you wouldn't need their money yeah so
that would give you a certain amount of
Freedom right right so yeah I mean I
understand that idea yeah uh so if you
if you need their money you become a
puppet I guess we said that already you
know instead of saying not need money
it's not for sale okay so you're not you
know okay let's put that slash has their
own money whatever okay what else
because I think this is very important
because for me let me explain to what
I'm doing here with you so our staff
were sitting there we're having a
conversation about who we need the
specific chief executive position that
we're trying to hire for and there's
debate amongst the group board who's the
person to hire one groups and I think is
this person that person this person and
we're having a very very big debate I
said before we have this wasted time
debating this write out the job
description and the qualities of this
individual to fit the criteria and then
let's go recruit that person right
that's what I'm doing right now so so
far for us to have somebody that is not
afraid to go up against these bullies
that we know from both sides this is
what we have so far honesty Integrity is
not for sale has their own money thick
skin courage what else would you say do
we want to add anything else to this
compassion right compassion she wants
what he's going to care about that I
agree that's a good one good call Rob
what else would you say I mean this is
you know what what else would you put on
this list here somebody said conviction
okay conviction is is there anything
else you want to add to it I think
that's that's
so so for me when when you when you
explain this to me
I I uh
I hate to say this and I know people are
gonna lose their minds when I say this
including yourself there's only one name
I think about uh-oh but you know you
know the name who
there's only one name you put on this
list here you're gonna put Trump there's
only one name what's the name he said it
Trump let me explain to you why but by
the way let me explain to you why though
let me explain to you why the challenge
with everything you said when you said
well you know he didn't even do it look
at him he said he's gonna go to the CIA
and then Schumer said what you know you
realize what they're gonna do you
realize they got six all this stuff that
you said about CI of course
you do you think a take a company that's
been around for 20 years
let's change it take a company that's
been around for two years okay they got
42 employees
you become a CEO
are those people who are 42 employees
are they fully fully loyal yet or it's
just too start of a company they can
still say no we need somebody that knows
what they're doing they'll flip to you
immediately if you're a good CEO right
okay take a company that's 10 years and
you come in maybe there's a little bit
more loyalty it's going to be hard to
flip these guys right take a company
that's 40 years you're going to have a
hard time flipping so you got to fire a
lot of people right take a company
that's 100 years take a company that's
been around since 1776. let's just call
this company USA okay and you come in
and you want to really the way these
guys have been Country Club politicians
and you want to break that apart or you
you don't have one enemy you don't have
two enemies you don't have a hundred
enemies you have hundreds if not
thousands of enemies who will not let
you ruin what they've been able to
convince the American people of doing to
be able to pull that off it takes a very
unique individual who is not going to be
liked by a lot of people who is
accustomed to not being liked who is
accustomed to having thick skin who is
accustomed to negotiating with dirty
people politicians business people he's
well dealt with everybody who's
accustomed for that I'm not telling you
he's the guy but if you're saying you
want somebody to go up against the
establishment I ask you names you
couldn't come up with names the lowest
score you gave out of all the
presidential candidates was only Trump
that's the lowest score you give out of
all the names and outside of Tulsa Gabba
because he gave Tulsi like a 50 is what
you gave you give Ron like a 50 I think
but Ron is not going to run Tulsa could
run this is not a regular person's job
is all I'm saying it's not a regular
person's job to be this person like the
other day you know AOC posted a picture
I don't know if you saw this or not
she posted a picture of uh uh of uh what
he called herself with Lula okay from
Brazil and you mentioned Brazil that's
why I'm bringing up Lula and if you see
this picture go all the way down keep
going down keep going that she tweets a
lot so it's kind of tough to catch him
you're probably not going to get to the
picture but it's a picture of her and
Lula okay and she says something about
it's so great to have a leader like this
who's Brave and courageous etc etc and
then two posts later you know what she
posts she posts a picture with Elon Musk
and Rupert Murdoch at Super Bowl and
then she says what birds like birds love
a feather flock together right and then
you're like wait a minute if that's the
case yeah what do you do two posts ago
you are Lula and Lula came to us I
retweeted Biden's picture and I said is
Lula in America to get another car wash
yeah if you know the car wash what he
did was stealing yeah all that stuff so
so the point all I'm saying this this
person Jimmy you're probably not going
to like the person to go up against
establishment you're probably not going
to like him
what do you think I would I I would I
would like Joe Rogan to run he ain't
gonna do it I know he won't do it but he
won't do it you know I think he I think
the world a lot of people would want to
have a guy like that run I don't know I
don't know I think he has all those
qualities I don't disagree and I don't
disagree and didn't come from The
Establishment because you know he wasn't
a politician but I wanted to ask you
when we were talking about it and I
think one of his biggest mistakes for
Trump was coming in and right off the
rip going I'm going to drain this swamp
and we've said this before in the
podcast Jimmy when you drain the swamp
if you think about you take all the
water and shut up you think alligators
and snakes are gonna go hey we're gonna
go to another they're gonna go crazy so
here's my thing and it's funny we're
talking about Carlin I was listening to
George Carlin on the way here and it was
like towards the end when he was like
with the government telling you it's a
big Club that's right none of us aren't
that so my thing is that Breaking Point
Jimmy that we're talking about that that
moment where we're in the streets and
I'm just like you I I I've sacrificed
some of my career because I finally
started talking about it and it really
bothers me that you know we're stuck in
this in this rut and I always say for
people to get into the streets but do
you think that this deep State and all
this the system is so set up against us
even if we have that moment Jimmy where
we're there we're we're ready to go they
own all the all the they own all the
government they own everything we kind
of can't really if we win the streets
patent was there actual Revolution the
National Guards getting deployed
everybody's all the cops everybody's
gonna turn on us because that you know
they run the show the government runs
all them how loud how loud do you think
that we can actually get and what would
be the breaking point for everybody to
go okay we're we're done do you think
there even is a Breaking Point well
that's what I keep asking that question
like what's happening right now in
Palestine Ohio I'm like when when are
people when are they gonna stop just
taking it I don't understand what ha so
it has to come from the Grassroots it
has to I think it has to come from a
worker-led kind of a thing and you know
more of a Christian Smalls kind of a
reaching out you know an economic
Alliance of the war of the classes
working class I mean so it is a class
war that's happening and so and they won
it's all over uh and and they control
that they can I mean it's just so
obvious that our our government is
completely controlled which is why they
can't give you Health Care while they
they can't bring clean water to Flint
Michigan you know they have billions of
dollars in the Ukraine age so they could
get clean water and you could but they
won't do that for the United States I
have a question for you Jimmy yeah this
is gonna be kind of a crazy question but
just go with me okay so we're railing on
the establishment right now the
establishment The Establishment The
Establishment so the argument these days
is should we just tear it all down and
start anew or fix sort of the problems
here's my question so when I think of
establishment I think of well the
Supreme Court I think of Congress I
think of uh the military I think of the
office of the presidency I think of NATO
I think of all the different alphabets
CIA FBI all every throw everything you
want in there right every single
Department of this education agriculture
isn't that what kind of made America
what it is today these establishments
now there's Bad actors within the
establishments that we need to get the
[__] out of there term limits Bad actors
lobbyists that are operating within the
Shadows of the government that they need
to get the hell out of their crazy
question but aren't these establishments
established for a reason and we just
need to have better people in there and
hold them accountable but also maintain
the establishments well you have to have
institutions I'm not that's what I mean
yeah institutions correct to have
institutions but look at a guy like
fauci right so a guy there he's there 43
years these are Bad actors bad people
yeah right to this system but it's not
the system of the NIH that's bad right
right the idea to have an FDA or a CDC
or nia idea this is these are good
things you need to have these things but
the way they're funded is completely
ridiculous right now the the big Pharma
funds the 70 of the FDA so they're
completely kept so we have corporate
capture of our Regulatory Agencies and
so that's what I'm talking about we need
to First first of all start getting
money out of politics so we can get our
our institutions back ours back to
serving the people instead of serving
press I agree with you we want to to
maintain these establishments yeah you
got to have these institutions but with
the right people so everything you want
to throw with the big in there right you
want to throw big Pharma uh the
military-industrial complex right uh uh
Big Oil big Tech all these big stuff
that have sort of corporatism has come
within these establishments and reached
around and grabbed their tentacles all
about them we just want to get them out
so I think the reason that I'm asking
this question is because we do want to
maintain these establishments we do want
to maintain what has made America great
for a lack of a better term but get the
nonsense out of it so I think it's like
a very nuanced
discussion and argument not [__] the
establishment we kind of need the
establishment to maintain America so why
was it like for instance a lot of people
would say hey why don't we nationalize
you know the oil industry right because
that's our oil that's the United the
country's oil it's not exxon's oil and
then whenever a country tries to do that
the United States tries to coup that
government right so yeah we I I wouldn't
expect even with the vaccine like other
people have made the point like why
wasn't that nationalized why were they
allowed to make a hundred million
dollars off of covid one company which
people have no idea how much money that
is you know the recording industry in
the United States every piece of music
that's recorded and released generates
12 billion dollars a year a hundred
billion dollars went to one company for
covet I mean that's the kinds and that
100 billion dollars is enough to buy
everybody in the media and by everybody
in government and that's we're living in
a corrupted place which is why people
think Ivermectin was horse Pace instead
of what it actually is uh a miracle drug
that has saved billions of lives and
it's safer than asp friend so they
wanted to make you think it was scary
that's because and it all started with
Bill Clinton in 1996 when he did the
Telecommunications Act and people don't
realize that we used to have 50 giant
media companies in America and then Bill
Clinton passed the Telecommunications
Act which took us down to six which is
why journalism sucked so hard in America
because they all work for the same
people they were right they were
competing for the licenses it was insane
by the way that's a very big point he
just made right there about the whole we
had we went from 50 to a handful uh and
that hurt a lot of uh people because you
didn't have more voices and until this
format came out where a guy like him or
Rogan or us or we can go out there and
talk and say what we're saying we're
like wait a minute what are these guys
toward these guys that kind of makes
sense let me Google this let me research
this but then you see the narrative is
we're we're all right we're mental we're
radical I don't know if they say that
about you but they say that about me
that I'm an all I'm all right conspiracy
theorist because I was right about
russiagate I was right about Syria I'm
right about kovid and so that's what
they so they have narrative control and
if you look at the journalists and the
Twitter is the perfect example when the
Twitter files came out and mataibi was
exposing stuff like that and uh they
were all shooting on him as if he's some
kind of an idiot for doing breaking a
story about Corruption of social media
and the government and so you see
they're the narrative control that's
what journalism is that's what corporate
journalists are there for to control the
narrative and if they don't control the
narrative they have to start
disappearing people and that's a lot
harder yeah very important part about
the narrative like for instance you just
called yourself a lefty your words and
now you're a quote unquote alt right
that they call me which one are you
Jimmy I'm Lefty but this is the problem
this try to discredit me by calling me
all this is the problem and I just kind
of revisit what you were talking about
earlier with Putin for example this is
the problem with just dismissing and
throwing a label on somebody so it's so
easy to be like Putin's crazy yeah or uh
or zelinski is a hero that's right and
that's it and and most people what I
often say are most people are most
people we talk about like most people
are living paycheck to paycheck trying
to get by raise their family raise their
kids [__] just day to day work to
work you want me to get into a nuanced
discussion about the Don bass region of
whether the military industry accomplish
is making money up Putin and the NATO
alliance it's like let me just try to
get paid in later over here okay right
buddy so that it's just easy to just
label Putin's crazy silinski's the hero
he's gonna be the man of the year all
right cool Jimmy's all right let's keep
it moving bye but it's not so simple
like that that's your point that's great
and going back to what you're saying
though when you said you know aren't
some of these you know FDA aren't some
of these uh you know Institute not
institutions or somebody
departments whatever you're going to
call them necessary okay so in a company
when a person comes in you see how many
dumb departments there is that you're
funding you you you go through when you
hire a CFO to come in and you do a
higher forensics auditing for your own
company that you're taking over you're
about to buy so you're about to buy a
company that's got a lot of issues you
come in you going to spend a lot of
money auditing that business so when we
were being bought there was people
auditing every single thing on what
statement expenses credit card what's
this what's that why are you spending
this money your Optics you're hiring how
everything is being audited right and
they're like dude this is a waste that's
a waste we can help you with this way so
then the buyer is sitting there saying
that's six hundred thousand dollars a
year you you uh putting here that it
will be a waste because we'll take it
don't worry about it we're gonna save
that money so that's an additional 600
000 on ebitda that million dollars
you're spending here that two million
dollars you're spending here we can save
money in those following areas right so
when a person comes in
this whole thing with Transportation uh
Czar which is who this wonderful guy
this this amazing guy
do you know do you know what we're
starting to realize with everything that
happened has he gone to any of the spots
by the way has he gone to Ohio has he
gone to Palestine has he gone to
Michigan has he gone to Detroit has he
gone to any of these places okay FYI the
same guy that you didn't like let me ask
you a question if this guy was President
the guy you don't like honestly Jimmy
honesty
if this guy was president today
you're you're a straight up guy how long
before he goes to Palestine you mean
Trump yes how long before he goes to
Michigan how long before he goes to the
board he was president and he didn't fix
the water in Flint Michigan you're
expecting him to do it in what in four
years in four years while he's getting
trash with Russia no I mean well he's
got a hundred other issues he's dealing
with because here's here's again this is
what it goes back to the challenge with
you wanting the candidate
your uh your uh and by the way if we
think we've seen dirt and smear
campaigns on him we're about to see a
whole different and we're going to see
it on the sand and we're going to see
what are they going to find on Trump I
mean they're going to do it they're
going to do a lot of it except for him
he is now got the lead on smear
campaigns on all of them whatever
Twitter files everything that's coming
out and now that Elon Musk owns Twitter
it's a different game today than it was
in 2020 than today but this is the part
all I'm saying to you is if something
like that happened you got this
department that Pete's running you know
what the average person is thinking how
much money do we spend for this
department of you know whatever
Transportation can you find out what is
our budget for Department of
Transportation because what did they do
okay maybe we don't need that department
how much money are we spending so depart
with what you're saying is yes some of
those things may be necessary but the
budget is too much of a budget can we do
it on half the budget who do we need to
fire why do we have this many employees
why do we have that many employees why
do it's the cut that we need to do okay
great yes no problem exactly we don't we
don't need to tear down institutions we
need to get the the the nonsense the
only problem is really spending out of
there the only problem with that is
which you know within eight years or
four years another guy's gonna come in
and he's gonna say let's fill it up
again let's fill it up again let's hire
87 000 new IRS agents let's hire boom
they're gonna do that again and fill it
up because we swap CEOs every four to
eight years
we swap CEOs every four to eight years
and every time that happens it's
dramatic and by the way it's we don't
just swap CEOs we swap philosophies so
we go we go Reagan we go you know senior
we go Clinton we go boom boom boom boom
boom boom go ahead I would disagree that
they have different philosophies that's
like I pointed out that Barack Obama was
not a departure from George Bush he was
in an extension of the George Bush Bill
Clinton was not a lesser of two evil to
Bob Dole the pets that's all you got to
vote you got to vote I mean to George
Bush and or Bob Dole uh because George
Bush couldn't do the things that Bill
Clinton could do to hurt workers for
instance NAFTA George Bush the first
tried to pass that pass NAFTA he
couldn't get the blue dog Democrats to
go along with them Bill Clinton gets
elected he gives them cover now because
he's a southerner he's a blue and he's
the president so he gives them and then
they get it done they passed adapter
which takes the legs out underneath the
unions for a generation and then he guts
welfare at the same time as he uh then
does the deregulation of Wall Street
which again then uh led to the economic
shutdown of our country 10 years later
and who got hurt the worst not the
Millionaires and billionaires but
against the poor poor and workers right
Jimmy so you're a pro-union yeah
now the problem with the unions in the
United States there's is that they I
don't think that I mean I'm not a
specialist I mean I've been in a couple
unions myself but I'm not a specialist
on unions but it looks like they're
corrupted and they're part of the
professional managerial Academy of
course yeah they don't really part of
the camp yeah they're part they're also
bought I know so for you to say you're
Pro uni so so you so again for me Jimmy
I I I but Christian Smalls Union is a
great you know there's lots of unions
there you need unions you definitely
need unions I mean if you don't have you
I mean Jesus Christ they they dude look
at what's happened to the freaking
railroad workers just now they won't
even give them freaking sick days and be
and they have a union and the government
comes in and crushes their Union because
they were going to win that strike and
that's why that Governor that government
had to do that and that's real fascism
by the way if you would because I I
generally don't have the answer on
unions I don't think it's all good or
all bad if you could have this
discussion what are the pros and cons of
unions you probably are going to take
the cons perspective no so okay so my
opinion okay is these things start with
good intentions
but this is the challenge of me and when
you mentioned the lady earlier and then
Vinnie said should they have their own
money and he said well she doesn't have
money but I don't think she can be
bought let me tell you okay and I'll
give you an analogy maybe this will make
sense to you
are you married yeah how long have you
been married
uh 10 12 13 years okay so were you good
with the ladies when you were younger
I'm assuming you were because you're
good with uh you can talk I I had some
girlfriends okay but you you weren't shy
amongst girls yeah okay so I want you to
think about this here uh so imagine if a
guy is not good with girls okay and he's
only been with one his entire life and
he's now 35 and he's not married and but
he's only been with one okay he's just
horrible with girls
but all of a sudden at 35
you know he's now married and he's got a
couple kids and now he becomes Super
Famous and he starts making a lot of
money
and he becomes the best whatever you
know coder at his company and he joined
Snapchat and there's an exit and he
makes 35 million dollars okay
so all the girls that were working at
Snapchat now are coming up to him oh my
God Bobby you're such a great coder man
I love can we go for a drink he's like
I've never had this experience before
damn one [__] two oh my God three that
was cool dude left and right okay
if you're a guy you've never had play
then all of a sudden you get a lot of
attention you don't know how to handle
it that's correct okay the same to me
goes with money if you're a politician
you've never made money you become a
politician and you all of a sudden want
to do the right thing then Pfizer knocks
on the door most of the time you're for
sale okay if you're a union worker
you're creating the union for the right
reasons then the people with money show
up and say hey Mr uh uh Jimmy gaffa or
whatever your name is okay hey you know
or this Union Leader we got this leading
such and such here's what we're going to
do we think you're underpaid
okay let's strike up a deal and we're
willing to do XYZ for you but we'll do
this and we'll give you more power and
you'll be locked in for 10 years 15
years with this position but we'll give
you XYZ money that's the problem with a
lot of these politicians and union
leaders they start off with good and
then therefore sell because they've
never experienced real money before what
do you think well I don't I I I've seen
it happen right so I think there's a lot
of Truth to what you're saying for sure
uh we've seen it happen I don't know
what it is like like we just saw uh
uh they get booked like for instance I
I'm focused on the squad right uh
because those are supposed to be the
people who don't take corporate money
they're supposed to be the people you
know standing up to the establishment
inside government they're not doing it
and so but they get book deals right
like Corey Bush just got a book deal I
think she's you know I don't know how
many tens of thousands of dollars she
got for that but she probably sold two
books
so I mean that's how they get people so
you're right right so they do get people
um but I think there are people who
could stand up against it I think RFK
stood up against it there you go the the
Forerunner story of pain and
perseverance and America was released on
October 4th the publisher paid Bush and
anti-police socialist who stoked BLM
rights in 2020 in advance of fifty
thousand dollars Bush's financials
disclosure reports show Cory bush wow
and it sold 729 copies in its first week
crushing it
fifty thousand we might have just helped
her sell a couple more copies
for 7.29 that's a lot of money never
written a book and that's a lot of money
I wrote a book I got a book deal and
might had a great manager at the time so
he knew how to get me a good deal and I
think I got the last good deal you could
get without being super famous so my um
my manager at the time was this guy Alex
Murray he's a great manager and he got
me I don't know he he worked it out he
got me twenty thousand dollar advance
for my book oh I could to believe it I
was like that's amazing man because I
don't I don't know how to write a book I
can't even read yeah you're like I don't
even know
imagine book comes out 367 uh spelling
errors in here but it's awesome you know
it's awesome book anyways uh so let's go
to a completely different topic let's go
to a complete different topic I just
want to get you this this could be a
little bit of you know for we can have
fun with this one but I I want to I want
to see what you say about this did you
see the Chelsea Handler clip about what
it is to be single have you seen this
one or no oh this is awesome I love this
one since you haven't seen it I'm gonna
enjoy this even more do you have it
Robert okay right there so we're gonna
get the original OG reaction of Jimmy
have you seen this Adam or not
phenomenal both of you enjoy this so
here's the benefit of being a childless
woman this is the day in the life of a
childless woman watch this day in the
life of a childless woman I wake up at
6am I remember that I have no kids to
take to school so I take an edible
masturbate and go back to sleep I wake
up at 12 30 pm and get ready for a busy
day of doing whatever the [__] I feel
like I put on my most impractical and
stylish shoes since I won't be chasing a
child around the grocery store I go to
my fav spot in Paris to grab a croissant
I do a meditation sesh on the plane
since I have no screaming kids allowing
me all the Time in the World to become
enlightened the weightlessness of my
existence has granted me superhuman
Powers I teleport myself back home then
I get ready for a night out with
whatever hot guy I met on Raya that
morning I call up a babysitter and tell
her that I don't need her since I still
don't have kids now it's time for a
workout so I hit Mount Everest for a
quick climb I invent a time machine go
by back in time and kill Hitler crazy
bastard it's amazing what you can do
when you have this much free time and
that's a day in the life of a childless
woman she looked unhappy well she
doesn't have a job either
right I mean I just got triggered but
but Jimmy Pat from you guys watching
Adam I think she's really sad like she
she doesn't look that smile isn't like a
real I felt the same way do you feel
that yeah
she looks like she's hurting yes let me
tell you one thing wow I agree with one
thing she did in that entire [__]
video she went back and killed Hitler
okay yeah that's good let me tell you
the problem with ladies like this by the
way can we just pull up for age real
quick I'm guessing late 40s um no what
did you say I wasn't gonna say I'm
guessing 41. 52. what do we got give me
an age 52 46 she's 47. all right so I
was off by a year here's the problem
a few years ago when she was 42 43 and
she kind of still had her looks and she
was allegedly banging 50 Cent and
this this Sex in the City I do what I
want to do I could go where I want to go
that was cute
when you're 50 and no dude this hot dude
you meet on Raya they're not gonna exist
any anymore for you Chelsea
period and the problem is this it's like
for every one Chelsea Handler that
thinks this way yeah there's a million
50 year old women that were fed this
[__] that are like [__] you Chelsea
Handler for me and for indoctrinating me
I watch sex in the city I was told I
don't need no man I was told that I can
just do what I want to do and Gallivan
off to Paris and jerk off in the middle
of the day and have fun and have my wine
it's like let me tell you what's going
to end up with those women at the end of
the day they're going to be uh
non-married no kids 17 cats 14 dildos a
couple different vibrators and sad A F
this is not a good business model for
you to live your life off of foreign
like a hostage video yeah because
imagine she's she's gonna be 50
something yeah she's gonna have the cats
and all that stuff but I mean I think I
think deep down inside you want to have
some kids I think I would like to have I
didn't have kids so I missed that when I
was supposed to have kids I was doing
comedy and then I got not too late for
you Jimmy it is you wanna you wanna
adopt Vinnie take Vinnie what but I
don't have any so I was I would like to
I was thinking of adopting right because
you want to have someone to bury you and
uh that's the number one reason and the
number one doesn't have anybody to bury
me should be that's hilar I mean it's
sad but it's hilarious Pat why did you
show this video of all things we could
be discussing today UFOs flying saucers
everything in train wrecks everything
China what made you go with this Chelsea
Handler I mean we've been talking about
this what a waste of a life yeah what a
waste of life and you know for somebody
that buys into that life a miserable
lonely life everything in life to me
that has value is stuff that outlives me
and it's great relationships and that
takes a long time time that takes a very
very long time again if you've been
through the fast life and you've gone
through it where it's like another one
and another one and another one and you
and I were having this conversation
regularly where I'm like look how many
more you want to do you know how many
more you want to go through you know
what else are you going to be doing this
is a hero to who I mean you know what
that reminded me of is when I wanted to
have a kid and I was talking to my wife
about
um adopting and I just kept having the
same you know idea in my head was the
reason why I want to have a kid is
because I want to stop thinking about
myself 24 hours a day I'd like to put my
energy into loving something else and
building something else up and that's
she was I mean of course it's a comedy
sketch yeah we got that yeah but um you
know that seems like the opposite of
that so just think about it's just
that's the problem I think I'm
experiencing with not having kids is I
spend too much time thinking about
myself I'll give you a complete opposite
side for you to be thinking about okay
thank God she didn't have any kids okay
because the world would have two or
three more Chelsea handlers okay
I don't disagree but here's the part as
well I think too many of the uh we
talked about this on the last podcast I
think I was in uh Orlando yesterday and
in Vegas yesterday I gave a talk in
Orlando and I gave a talk in Vegas and
then I flew back last night and the
group I spoke to in Orlando in in Vegas
my message was about some of you guys
got to choose to start having four five
six seven eight kids that's just one or
two I'm dead serious with you I'm
telling you I think the right parents
need to have more kids a man named John
Morris who was our chair at vistage in
La great guy powerful guy in people know
him in Santa Monica money guy venture
capital guy and he was our Mentor he was
60 at the time give or take and
one day I'm having a conversation with
them I'd have my monthly one-on-ones
with them and I said hey John how many
kids you got he says two I said wow why
two you know you think you made the
right choice with two he says biggest
mistake of my life I said really two
kids biggest mistake I guess his biggest
mistake of my life and so why is that he
says the moment
I got good
at being a parent I stopped having kids
tell me what thing in life do you stop
doing after you become great at it
biggest mistake we should have had four
more kids he got me thinking I came home
I sold that I told that to Jen my ID was
I want to have five to ten kids is what
I wanted have we ended up with four we
were supposed to have five twins good
you know one didn't make it but you know
God's blessed us in a great way and life
is irregular Alec Baldwin huh regular
Alec Baldwin is that what it is he's got
like seven kids now oh dude I would have
20 kids I'm telling you right now I
would have 20 kids if I had them my way
but you know it's it's it's a different
life but also at the same time there's a
part where it's like good for you for
not having one because let's just say if
she did have a kid she probably would do
it out of wedlock and she would probably
sell the same exact philosophies to her
and that kid's probably gonna be living
the same exact life as well as she is
and doing what she's doing so I don't
know uh this message unfortunately is
going to inspire some people for every
Andrew Tate you have to have a Chelsea
Handler you're the extreme arguments of
both sides let them hash it out and
debate it and then see who's going to
come up you know long-term winning I
don't know can I add to that with the
entertain number one I don't think this
is breaking news ironically Andrew Tate
does have kids yeah okay so like he does
he and he's advocating having kids so
here's the problem I have with this can
you imagine if some dude was like yep
not having kids just could meet him just
pouring in on the [__] y'all just I'm
out there making my money no kids no
wife I'm just driving my cars I don't
want no kid weighing me down I'm going
to Paris I'm having fun I'm jerking off
all day saying that as a guy dude you
just got canceled what are you talking
about what are you saying right now no
guy could say what she's saying and
here's the harm with Chelsea
can't say that yeah Vinnie you go out
and say that unless yeah I'm finished
here's the problem with Chelsea for
everyone Chelsea's uh Handler that does
this for attention clearly it's not like
she's saying in this in the mirror every
day and she's got 10 and a half million
views on Twitter
it's a freak Show yeah but for every one
Chelsea's Handler doing this to get
views there's a lady named Debbie in
Ohio that's like yeah you tell him
Chelsea and there's a lady named Maggie
in Florida and Rebecca in California
that's living that life and they're
crying on the inside because they're
living Chelsea's life that's
romanticized of being just this selfish
individual succumbing to all your
individual needs well it's not
attractive when a guy does it that's why
that guy doesn't come around
gallivanting like this and it's even
less attractive when a woman does it
maybe maybe I was projecting on to her
who knows like maybe you know I said her
smile didn't look real maybe it is real
and maybe I'm projecting because I feel
bad about myself not having kids but
Jimmy maybe that's a good chance cool
when you're a lady and you say that when
you're 25 and it's kind of cool when
you're 35. not when you're nearly 50.
it's sad and disgusting here's here's
the part that all of us have to deal
with and we have this conversation with
our uh the guy that we love the world
loves uh not broken or a handsome friend
no Mike bro micro was here I'm thinking
of handsome man and by the way micro you
know saying 60 never married never can
never had kids never heard never and
that good looking of a guy like he is
like an all-around American guy that you
know a girl would want to be with
uh came straight he's straight I think
he's straight I I would have to say he
is straight I don't I don't know
personally but I would say he is
straight okay you know the one
conversation we had at the end of the
video this is like a straight guy there
you go and press it impressive
here's the part here's the part
we're all sales people when somebody
tells me I can't sell I've never been
good in sales [__] you've been
selling for your entire life on whatever
the lies you believe in or whatever the
truths you believe in you're a
salesperson okay you can sell anything
you want to other people as if you're
happy with the decision you made but
then you have to be by yourself and when
you buy yourself only one person knows
if you're happy with the decision you
made Chelsea's selling that life but by
the way if she's by herself she's a
hundred percent fully happy with the
decisions she made guess what more power
to you I'm just not convinced she is no
that's the only thing so let's go to the
next story let's go from Chelsea to
Demar Hamlin yeah which we've all seen
that hit we've all seen the fall we've
all seen the jacket at this point the
Super Bowl he came and apologized and he
talked to his mom and dad and he says
look this is not something I support it
was I was just being fashionable so I'm
not even talking about the jacket we had
an interview with Michael Strahan and by
the way I can't believe Michael Strahan
actually asked the question did you see
that the fact that he asked yeah and the
fact that ABC was okay with him asking
it ABC has to prove all the questions
you asked I know but he asked the
question that's the establishment here's
what the question was and and look at
the answer that Demar Hamlin gave go
ahead
to the question on so many Minds what
caused his heart to stop beating you're
24.
Peak physical condition can run circles
around me right now
how did Doctor describe what happened to
you
um
yeah
oh my god do I do it or do I not
something I want to stay away from
me
by the way Michael didn't go and say why
the obvious follow-up question and he's
a great interviewer you're supposed to
ask what here's a question do you think
the why Woods asked what ABC cut it
do you think the why Michael is a great
interviewer well he asked that first
because by the way go back 10 seconds
look how abrupt it is go back 10 seconds
and look how immediately it goes into
that it doesn't make sense but play the
clip again
um
that's something I want to stay away
from I know from my experience
I believe that's an edit I agree okay I
believe Michael asked the why and they
cut it yes I agree we know about editing
around here yes that guy say one thing
and a lot of people don't understand
obviously I this is my opinion like we
always say it has to do something about
either he had covet or the vaccine which
nobody's had said if he said or not I
want to say Pfizer is one of the biggest
donors to the NFL you know that right
120 million dollars so 100 and over 120
million dollars rob you can look it up
and I uh mind you Jimmy when you go
after somebody like that big Pharma are
we done with the video by the way yes
well yeah look what they did with James
O'Keefe James O'Keefe yeah that guy
talking [__] about them mutating this
virus what happened to James O'Keefe one
week later they made an example they
made an example of them number one
number two
um uh a study there's a Smith Heart
Institute study just showed that uh
heart attacks and deaths are from 2000
to 2022 are up 30 from ages 25 to 44
years old it's all going up and Robert I
was going to send you the link on it
it's a it's a Heart Institute study cult
Pfizer does not play games and their CEO
I forgot where is Albert Berlin Albert
Berlin was doing a speech on one of
those worlds that can one of those
forums where they just said on stage and
dispute [__] he was like we have all
these Vex because you know a vaccine
hesitancy we have all these vaccines
that I nobody's we gotta find a way to
get people more motivated to take this
thing that's right it's insane that you
saw fear did you see the fear where I
saw the wheels turning in his head and
the wheels were do I tell people the
truth or do I know that I was told to
shut the hell up and don't say anything
because my career is well obviously he
was he's been coached to not talk about
that in a certain way and he was like
well what can I say and not jeopardize
what I whatever the deal is I was given
yeah uh so I mean that's if you can
watch that and not have red flags going
off all over the place then you're you
know uh you're brain dead but uh the
thing is people would say well the
increase in heart attacks are from covet
because covert cause heart attack
although they did a huge study in the
Israeli study said it didn't so
um the point I it does my thing is
around covid and the vaccines is like
for the first time in my lifetime we
weren't allowed to question anything at
all uh and if you did you were a white
supremacist and Trumper and it was the
great I mean I'm like no I just want to
get informed and you know what they
would say they go please don't do your
own research you know before covet don't
do your own reasons they would say don't
I'd see comedians on stage in Los
Angeles saying that folks please don't
do your own research you know before
covet doing your own research just meant
reading yeah and now they've shamed
reading that's how big Pharma has gotten
people it's like I woke up in the middle
of the building well it looks like we
got ourselves a reader oh one
the Bible said it was true you wouldn't
tell that to anybody else like this what
I say is like if I was gonna go buy a
car you would go hey don't look into it
well how am I supposed to know what
Carter don't you do one of them things
now Jimmy is driving my ass ask the
salesman he's the expert what are you
Henry Ford
I mean people who have question
authority bumper stickers told you to
just shut up and stop asking questions
about the vaccine that's crazy yeah and
it's not people who still think we
haven't landed on the moon and Elvis is
still alive won't question the vaccine
it's the craziest thing the biggest
Skeptics are supposed to be Comedians
and cynics they totally dropped the ball
on this and uh and I I I I hope I never
go through something like this again and
you know just look just look what
happened with Ivermectin right how they
can make everybody in the country still
to this day think it's some kind kind of
poisonous drug that's bad for you
instead of what it actually is a wonder
drug you know they were looking at it to
cure cancer before covid and the way I
found out the way I found out that they
were lying about everything about kovid
was I got vaccine injured and I got put
into a study right so these doctors put
me in a study and their theory was that
the vaccine gave me long coveted
symptoms and they showed me I had to go
to a special place get a blood test and
they showed me my biological markers
were exactly like somebody who had long
covet except I never had covet so then
they gave me these drug cocktail it was
a zithromycin Ivermectin uh fluvoxamine
there's a couple other things all the
good stuff and I said hey that
Ivermectin man that's that horse poison
right and the guy that my doctor was
like hey Jimmy he's and he told me all
that stuff he says before covid this was
considered a wonder drug it's safer than
aspirin it saved billions of lives the
reason why they're doing that is because
it's been shown to be able to treat
covid in the lab and that if it can
treat covid they can't get their
emergency use authorization for their
vaccines and so that's why I had to say
that about hydroxychloroquine and they
had to say the same thing about
Ivermectin and that's a fact that's why
and so now we know that's a lie and
people just ignore it like as if it
never happened or how about when they uh
the new lie is well we never said the
vaccine would stop transmission and
control so of course you did I got video
after video but people don't want to
know that it went from 100 to 90 to 80.
hey give it a shot that's so when I got
vaccine injured I found out they were
lying about masks they were lying about
herd immunity they were lying about
natural immunity they were lying about
transmission they were lying about
contraction and they were lying about
funding the virus the the research that
led to it they were lying about where it
came from and if you said it came from
the lab you're a white supremacist
racist racist China China virus you hate
yeah do you think do you think they're
going to investigate it do you think
they're going to go through an invested
who are they going to get to investigate
it you know what I mean they're all
they're all part of it right so it's
going to take a real and Paul's not a
Rand Paul will challenge it and he Rand
Paul did he stood up against fauci vouch
he lied Fouch he lied to Rand Paul which
is lying to Congress twice he asked him
if he funded gain of function research
at the Wuhan lab he said no twice and
then the NIH said you know what we
actually did do it [__] she's lying yeah
and and Jimmy we talked about this on
the last podcast they'll never be held
accountable never but I would I would
literally pay like I started GoFundMe
page for millions and millions of bucks
Jimmy just because you know lie detector
tests are only admissible in court
they're not admissible of course they're
not miss what I'm saying but you know
what they're admissible to the to the
public if you want to prove to these
[__] like fauci or Hillary or any of
them well we'll have this big fund you
come we'll ask you the general questions
but then the one question we'll ask you
did you do this hold them accountable do
take a lie detector test oh you watched
the first 48 they sent them detectives
go you want to do a lie detector sit in
here we don't have to use it in court
but I want to know if you're full of
[__] so there's a lawsuit now and so
papouchi was actually been deposed and
most of the questions he was like I
don't remember oh that's all they have
to say I don't recall I don't recall let
me ask you guys a question I don't want
to go full uh conspiracy rear wrist here
um we talked about establishment but
also big Tech and big Pharma and all
their hands and everything
the CEO of YouTube just uh stepped down
oh no did you hear about that no I
didn't yeah 25 years yeah I don't you
know this is the story go ahead right so
YouTube go I'll go right at the top so
Youtube CEO Susan wolshiki how do you
say her name oh I love it stepping down
after nearly a decade in that role she
will be succeeded by Neil Mohan utep's
current
Chief product officer and if you go down
by the way that's a picture of her at
the world where the world economic forum
is there's establishment buddy
she's stepping down from YouTube after
nearly a decade in the role she has uh
she said in a blog post Thursday that
she plans to focus on her family that's
what they all say health and personal
projects shove an advisory role to
parent company Google and alphabet which
owns YouTube Here's the last part Neil
Mohan Chief product officer will be the
new head of YouTube according to the
blog post he this is now effective
immediately the time is right for me and
I'll be able to do this because I have
an incredible leadership team plays at
YouTube says Miss ojiki
anyway so she said she's gonna do uh
what did she say she's gonna do family
no what was the third thing she said
personal project yeah I think she wants
to be a YouTuber next that's what she
wants I could probably get up there
any correlation with the heat that's
being turned up on these questions
because of like the Twitter gate just
all the stuff that's kind of coming out
censorship what's going on questioning
Authority you think this is any
relevance I will I mean I wouldn't doubt
it uh but I think uh I just want to make
one more point about fauci is that when
you know that the Dallas Buyers Club you
remember that movie starring Matthew you
know just talking about that earlier the
bad guy in that movie is Dr fauci and
everybody forgets the reason why they
had to do the Dallas Buyers Club was
because fauci and the government were
keeping drugs that could help people
away because they only wanted to push
the drugs that were approved by big
Pharma and that's why they had to do the
goddamn Dallas the same [__] they did
with AIDS they're doing with coven the
same [__] and why did they do it with
Kobe because they got away with it and
they're gonna get away with it and
they're always going to get away with it
and we also learned uh in a podcast I
believe with zooby that one of two
countries in the world United States and
New Zealand I believe was are the only
countries that are allowed to advertise
full-on advertise on TV and what which
ones were the craziest on covet New
Zealand right oh my God Australia
Australia Australia but Australia they
were like you you are getting that they
were going to people's house remember
yes people at their [__] houses like
get out get you have to stay stay in
your hot like Australia they'd send you
to a camp yeah but let me ask you let's
give maybe the American people credit
for a second just for a second okay do
you think that most people not all
because there's gonna be people that
sort of were like you know what whatever
just happened with covid and these
lockdowns and these mandates and can't
say this and zip it up and shut your
mouth and get in line that it's it's
almost like fool me once you know shame
on you fool me twice shame on me like
people I've sort of woken up to like
like all right this authoritarian you
know mandates it ain't happening again
do you want to give the American people
a little bit of credit they won't let
that happen I don't know or do you think
that we're all just [__] sheep and
we're all just following I live in
California they just passed a law uh
super majority Democrats in the
legislature with the Democratic governor
and they just passed a law that
restricts doctors from practicing
medicine if they go against whatever big
Pharma says about covet there you go
that they'll find them so that's a chill
you're not supposed to do that that's
authoritarian and everybody just let it
happen now a judge they call it commune
now a judge has stopped it right but
that's California that's establishment
the judge I'm part of the establishment
so which way is it Jimmy thank God that
judge right yeah but you do you did see
the stats we've been kind of you know
making fun of it for a few years now
that Gavin Newsom is the U-Haul uh
employee of the year but stats just came
out just in fact how many people have
left California to get the hell out of
this Texas biggest Tennessee Florida the
whole deal yeah the stats are out there
don't know Rob if you want to pull that
out it's out yesterday I got the phone
call we were talking about earlier my
mom called me about a dozen and a half
eggs and she said something like 20 some
dollars and I was like she's a little
older I go mom you mean like 15 like not
it can't be she goes Vinnie she sent me
a picture a dozen and a half eggs were
were in the 20 and I'm like no way how
much is I'm not joking how much is gas a
gallon Cali average I think it's around
five or six bucks I think it's six bucks
maybe it got up to eight but I think it
came down and now it's around five or
six bucks unbelievable how the hell do
people survive California but I want to
know so they spend most of their money
on housing like the in Calif are you
supposed to spend thirty percent thirty
percent of your gross income I think in
California it's 50. right yeah then how
do you have money for car payment I
don't know food and beverage
only fans and selling drugs you know you
know what's gonna happen is
you know you're supposed to take give or
take 10 of your paycheck to put it into
retirement fund whatever
how many people in California that are
just living you know 50 of the house
food and beverage car payments yeah
everyone has to have a car in California
they're going to retire with zero
dollars in their bank account when they
go to retire it's going to be an ugly
situation but let me ask so you you know
everything I don't know anything about
money
but you know we should do since you
don't know about money get your own
podcast you got twenty thousand dollar
advance on a book what do you mean
Jimmy blowing up game in the system what
so I I put my retirement I didn't want
to put in the stock market uh so I put
in an annuity and everybody's like
you're stupid for putting in an annuity
but now the stock market's good so then
I did I started putting in a 401k but
that's going to crash now right well
it'll come back up you think long term
or short term you think long term it'll
it'll be come back it always does
because we're going to lose the Petro
dollar right now that's what the so Joe
Biden's Shenanigans in China and Russia
is going to screw the petrol dollar I'm
just going to stop here right now what
are you talking about right now I think
that's gonna affect the entire stock
market unbelievable I'll tell you God so
if you don't know what the petrol dollar
is I'll explain it so in the 70s Nixon
took us off the gold standard right and
so he went to the petrol dollar which
was we guaranteed or we promised the use
of our military to Saudi Arabia wherever
they wanted it which is why we're
committing a genocide in Yemen uh in
exchange for that if you were going to
buy oil from Saudi Arabia any other
country in the world they'd had to
change their money into U.S dollars and
so then they could buy the oil in U.S
dollars and that's called the petrol
dollar now what does that do it makes
every country decide well I'm going to
keep a bunch of US Dollars and then they
just started using it for other stuff
too so that's how the US dollar became
the reserve currency of the world and
now Saudi Arabia because of the [__]
we're doing with Russia to start and
China they're starting to sell oil in
other denominations than the US dollar
they're sending it to China right
China's what is it called the one the
one and there's I think I think it's
India maybe even Italy uh is this the
brick thing no constantly and then the
bricks thing's happening so there's a
shift that is going to happen because of
American American imperialism and
hegemony and when we are no longer the
reserve currency doesn't our economy
collapse yeah so to me here's here's a
couple things you got to think about
with that you notice earlier when we
were talking about our sponsor gold and
I give a shout out to them and it's like
hey a small percentage put it there uh
the only way your age right now you're
57 I think I looked at the numbers so
you got I don't know if you're going to
be retiring it's a different story of
retirement today versus but you got a
YouTube channel that's a that's the best
annuity you got by the way the AdSense
that's going to be paying you you're
it's not your 401k doesn't compare to
your YouTube channel that you have
that's the ultimate AdSense if you do it
right sponsorship you're doing all right
with patreon all that stuff having said
that let's just say you are an average
guy that doesn't have a YouTube thing
and you are dealing with a 401k it
depends on what age you want to retire
it depends on uh
your risk tolerance it depends on all of
that stuff but this is one way of
looking at it the whole climate change
argument okay once uh uh the AOC gets up
and says you know the world's coming to
an end in 12 years and then your best
friend the girl you like the most uh
Greta Greta who just she's coming out
with a new book if I'm sure you ordered
a degree I love her yeah so Greta's got
a new book coming up about climate
climate change the best way to gauge if
these things are real climate change is
go talk to actuaries who run these big
insurance companies whose jobs is to
protect a billion dollars because one
thing insurance companies hate is to pay
out money they do not like paying out
any of their money and you know you
notice long term they don't have a
challenge but what's going to happen
with the market with climate change if
they did they would be investing in
different places the whole real estate
on the water what's going to happen with
homes in Florida if it's that bad why
are insurance companies you know
offering the insurance to these homes on
the water or else is it going to be an
issue 100 years from now probably is it
going to be an issue 50 years from now
probably is it going to be an issue in
the next 10 20 years probably not so the
actuaries job is to sit there and
calculate risk everything's about that
so the Petro dollar the fiat currency
whatever way we want to put it could
that collapse uh could America go
through the mess they're going through
right now if we don't pay our debts the
biggest scariest number to be thinking
about is the following this is the
craziest number
in 2019 uh uh we paid 350 billion
dollars on interest of our debt in 2020
our debt interest payment was half a
percent we were paying 350 billion
2021 was 0.1 percent it went lower we
still paid 350 billion dollars in
interest 2022 last year our interest
went up to 1.9 average we paid 464.70
here's the crazy part just Q4 of 2022
Jimmy we paid 213 billion dollars of
interest just cute four at a 1.9 percent
average right now we're on a four and a
half to six percent run rate this year
this will be the first year where
America is going to pay over a trillion
it could be a trillion to a trillion and
a half we pay interest in interest in
interest only in interest only you're
already your debt is already climbing
heavily now add a trillion dollars of
interest and credit card payments in
America credit card debt in America's
943 Heist we've ever had it and savings
is declining last month our savings rate
was 2.4 percent we're not saving a lot
of money right that's a 17 year low
those are the things to really be
concerned about on what's going to
happen with the market now what this guy
Jimmy's trying to do in uh uh Powell's
trying to do with the rates with
inflation to try to kind of calm it down
uh you know the more and more and more
he keeps increasing it the more and more
and more he keeps increasing it
inflation isn't dropping as quickly as
people are thinking he still has to
increase rates and there's a story that
just came out which is pretty
interesting this kind of tells you
what's happened to the real estate
industry this is a Wall Street Journal
story about real estate if you can pull
this one up uh uh uh and if you can tell
me what page this is on let me find this
story okay here you go it's a as home
sales slow Realtors go back to other
jobs that's wholesale slow Realtors this
is not like a regular article Breitbart
this is Wall Street Journal right so
home sales are slowing because of
interest rates interest rates but
wouldn't so wouldn't the home so every
people still want to demand but but it's
not interest rates it's a good question
you ask okay it's greed it's not
interest rates it's great there's a
house in our community that I'm trying
to uh uh buy for somebody in my family
okay they're asking 1.294 they were
asking 1.7 million a year and a half ago
so they went to 1.6 1.5 1.4 now it's
1.29 that house is worth 7.50
but they're asking 1.29 okay so the 1.29
is these families every month or every
two months that they lower a hundred
thousand dollars guess what they're
starting to realize this is not worth
1.7 million anymore okay this is
probably going to end up selling for 900
000 800 000 so it's not interest rates
High interest rates are given a reality
check to homeowners that are being
greedy thinking wait for it we can sell
it for more wait for it we can sell it
for more wait for we can sell it for
more on a [__] pay lower by 100 Grand
lower by 100 Grand so it's greed that's
causing these Realtors to leave because
Realtors today don't know how to tell
the client Jimmy
can I tell you something yes what is it
you're going to get upset when I tell
you this Jimmy what's that your house
has not bored 1.5 million this is a 900
000 house what's the reaction Jimmy's
gonna have you know what now Jimmy I'm
gonna leave I'm the realtor I'm trying
to give some common sense here when I
leave guess what Jimmy's wife's gonna
say babe Fire Patrick immediately he's
clueless then he's going to call the
next realtor and any realtor is going to
say what just like any guy says on a
date with a girl I'm gonna change your
life and the realtor's gonna say Patrick
has no clue what he's this is at least
the 1.55 million dollar home then you
hired that Realtor then a realtor 90
days later guess what that Realtor has
to tell Jimmy Jimmy I have to break it
to you yeah this is an 800 000 house so
it's the relationship between the
realtor and the client right now that's
the conflict Realtors don't know how to
break it to the client that this house
is not put what you think it's worth I
don't think it's just a rate can I add
one thing real quick by the way when
we're talking about the realtors that
are going back to other jobs we're not
talking about the top 10 percent of
Realtors top 20 it we're not even
talking about the top 50 we're talking
about all the guys and gals that saw
what was happening in 2020 and like hold
on let me get on the bandwagon and they
were cook chefs Uber drivers whatever
photographers whatever and they got
their real estate license by the way I
did the same thing in 2005. when I saw
everybody making money in real estate in
Miami I'm like oh I want to get my real
estate license then came 2008 crash all
right I'm done being a realtor so all
these fake Fly by Night Realtors they're
out and then it's the people who are
experts at this it's almost like the
people that want to start a podcast
everyone's doing a podcast next thing
you know you know times get tough all of
a sudden people drop out of the podcast
world it's the people who are in it for
longevity and the right reasons are
still in it so shout out to those
Realtors the people who are in it for a
quick Buck they're out of it so you
think I'm okay I don't have to worry
about where I put my money I think you
just keep in an annuity you're good what
yeah or for what time frame 10-year
five years three years it's very
different if you have no plans with your
401k over a 10-year period maybe look at
the allocations pay attention to it
closely you don't want to have your
stocks and 100 small cap stocks I don't
know what what type of equities you got
uh you know if you got the index and I
don't know what kind of annuity if it
was a variable annuity or an index
annuity or a fixed annuity those are
three different types of annuities you
gotta straight up fix them what was the
rate they gave you so it was five
percent but then after the fees it
actually turns out to be like three but
yeah period if you look up if you look
up an index annuity what an index
annuity does is made for Boomers an
index annuity would be you can get the
upside of how to Market us up to a
percentage so they'll say like hey if
the market does 38 you're capped at 12.
okay but if the market does minus 38
percent like 2008 guess what you're not
losing anything you stay at zero so it
gives you the zero to twelve so an index
annuity was designed specifically for
for Boomers and he gave the Best of Both
Worlds a fixed the movie and a variable
I feel good about that yeah
just do yourself a favor take all the
money go to Vegas put it all on black
baby what is it self-directed 401K what
is that or you can choose your
allocation strategy my brother says he
puts it into real estate
you know instead of putting it into the
stock market he does a 401k somehow
where he puts it into real estate is
that possible of course it is yeah yeah
to REITs you can put gold in your 401k
you can do 100 gold in your forward
really did you hear me Peter Thiel did
with his 401k or this Roth he really he
became a billionaire I mean the way he
did it that's not the average person
Jimmy if you want some consultation we
have an app called manect that you're so
funny you are funny what is that I don't
get the job by the way do you know about
the app connect it's a very interesting
app connect here's how my neck works you
know how many times people DM you and
they say Jimmy I'd love to talk to you
for 15 minutes man can we get on and
you're like dude I don't have time and
you also don't want to ask him for the
money okay well on minute it does one of
three things if a person wants to ask
you a question for DM text response
you'll say it's a hundred bucks but
you'll respond back 100 if you want to
respond with a video is 200 bucks but if
they want to do a 15 minute face time
with you it's 50 bucks a minute so
you'll have a 15 minute face time with
them 750 you'll make 80 minutes 20 so
minute app is made for influencers out
there who made that it's the guy that's
sitting in this room here with you my
neck it's our app yeah that guy right
yeah Thanksgiving did you make that up
you know how this app got started did
you made it yeah this app got started
because my lawyer charged me for a seven
minute call he charged me 30 minutes I
called him back I said bro we had a
seven minute call he says minutes roll
up I said what are you worth by the
minute he says no lawyer charges by the
minute I said I'd love it if there was a
company that I can pay lawyers by the
minute so instead of looking for it we
built a company called minute really do
you have a minute to connect let's
connect on my neck so Jimmy door if you
wanted to do FaceTime with people you
can be up there and Jimmy you could be
one of the experts but if you need help
with your uh fixed annuity or your uh
self-allocation 401k plan come talk to
me I'll charge you a hundred dollars a
minute funny are you are you a financial
guy too yeah yes I am oh really
that was the realest thing Jimmy said
all day yeah you know it's real when
they use this breath
so we're at the end of the podcast Jimmy
uh
guys if you enjoyed this podcast give it
a thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
more importantly Jimmy if you don't mind
laughing president I wasn't born here uh
but but he is the veteran I wasn't born
I mean doesn't that should not exit out
he's a veteran you should I think we
should maybe get rid of that law I think
so too do we have your vote Jimmy uh
yeah I would vote for Pat yeah okay
listen self-funded courage
Turn The Listener okay don't need
corporate money honest Integrity is not
for sale has their own money thick skin
courage compassion conviction come on
skin to the list it's there it's a good
list by the way before we leave today
next week's a pretty big we got a pretty
big show do we want to talk about it all
oh [__] next song
Jimmy what time's your flight what time
are you leaving after this today yeah my
flight's at 3 30. okay perfect so you
know what so you got any plans for lunch
or no no okay so you you'll have you'll
come with us but I want to show you what
we built we built we bought this
building
and it was sitting there for a year my
dad said buy this building you're not
gonna find a building that's close to
your house I bought it we have no clue
what to do with it we got an idea I
don't even know how long ago this idea
was six months ago or something like
that yeah and I said listen why don't we
turn into a comedy club so we turn into
comedy clubs
then then I said why don't we create it
for Studio where any podcaster can come
we put a 16-foot TV LED TV and it'll
have your logo your brand Jimmy dors
show whatever and you got your four or
five you know guests that are there and
you got 300 guests watching you do a
live podcast so we set that up and then
last week we had our first private event
there and we built a high-end Cigar
Lounge in the same exact building so you
come in there's a humidor there's a bar
there's pool there's uh what do you call
it poker table domino table private
boardroom in the back but it's only
buying the invitation I'll show you that
when we go to it and we're doing our
first ever live event next week yeah is
that really next week
they loved you you're amazing you're
awesome it's great having you on thanks
looking forward to doing this again if
you want to give your last plug for the
event you're doing in February this
Sunday in Washington DC Lincoln Memorial
are doing an A Rage Against the war
machine yes it's around Ron Paul will be
there Chris Hedges Tulsi gabbard uh me a
lot of people will be there can you put
the link in chat in description folks go
look it up this is the website here this
Sunday in DC libertarian party people's
party all coming together in DC go see
Jimmy and others that are going to be
there uh have a great weekend everybody
we'll do this again next week Jimmy
thanks for coming out bye-bye